les 10 et 17 mars date retenue pour
cette municipale partielle à
basse-pointe deux listes sont en lice
dynamique et prend 3 avec marie thérèse
casimir yeux et ensemble pour réussir
basse pointe avec un patrick mariello
martinique la première donne la parole
aux deux têtes de liste aujourd'hui
marie thérèse casimir youth bonjour
madame classe b rieuse bonjour et je
salue tous les martiniquais qui nous
écoutent le scrutin du 10 mars en grande
partie suite à la démission de plusieurs
élus de votre camp on vous a dit meurtri
affaibli en grande difficulté dans
l'incapacité de remonter une liste
finalement vous adversaires ont eu tout
faux
absolument parce que je ne pense pas que
je donne l'image de quelqu'un de
meilleur tri je pense au contraire
enfin je tiens à rectifier vous avez dit
les démissions de la liste dynamique
points 3 je veux dire ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est le fait de l'ancien
maire de mon prédécesseur qui a fait
démissionner tout sa liste donc il a
profité de cette opportunité de quatre
démissions d'adjoint pour justement
demandé à sa liste tout entière de
démissionner alors que pour vous vivez
tout cela est ce que vous considérez que
c'est un échec et de vos premières
années de mandature
pas du tout je pense que la politique
vous savez c'est une équation avec des
leçons qui coûte très cher donc par
conséquent je ne peux que positiver et
dire qu'il avait amené plus de sérénité
surtout lorsqu'on est face à ce que
j'appelle une immaturité à ce que je
crois que il faut se dire martinique du
point de vue politique toutes tendances
politiques confondues connais pas aussi
à vis de quelqu'un mais on est au
service d'un idéal d'un engagement et
d'une certaine motivation pour qu'on ce
que se payer le faire avancer il faut le
faire ce sera un message qu'il faudra
faire passer au niveau de la population
3 3 également et également parce que les
pointois ce soit d'abord et surtout des
martiniquais par conséquent je crois que
ce message s'adresse à et qu'on arrive
un à dépassionner les choses en a pas
évité de celle des querelles de
personnes parce que ça nous conduit
nulle pas reparler de sérénité letairis
casimir yeux sur vos adversaires
justement disent que cette élection qui
se déroulera dans quelques jours ce sera
une opportunité car l'enjeu sera
d'apaiser la commune
trop tiraillé trop divisés distille à
cause de votre action je crois que à
partir du moment où on veut mettre fin à
certaines méthodes autocratiques cessieu
qui a fonctionné pendant des années
c'est sûr que vous provoquez donc un
changement de mentalité par conséquent
ça peut pas faire plaisir
lorsque nous n'avons certainement pas
mes détracteurs et moi-même la même
définition du poème de serenity je crois
que nous avons par la baisse d'impôts
parce que la ville de basse pointe a
subi une hausse
je veux dire inqualifiable d'impôt soit
plus de 169 au sein en dix ans et nous
avons agi à la fois en interne et en
externe
en interne c'est sens 41000 euros de
rappel de salaire de nous avons inversé
au personnel alors lorsque certains
quelques agents quelques cadres
profitent grassement de certain nombre
de primes est d'ailleurs à cet effet je
rappelle que le préfet de région a écrit
à l'ensemble des collectivités pour
expliquer réexpliqué qui avait donc des
primes qu'ils n'étaient pas que le non
cumul plus exactement des primes était
formellement illégal même quasi meirieu
le thème majeur de la campagne pour vous
jusqu'à quoi l'attractivité de la
commune de spotter perdu des habitants
il n'y a plus une certaine qualité de
service et ce que disent également vos
adversaires basse-pointe a perdu des
habitants comme un sens de la martinique
perd des habitants depuis dix ans parce
que justement nous sommes confrontés et
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'on dit que la
matinée sera l'un des départements avec
la cause plus vieux de france et ça a
déjà commencé dans le nord et c'est bien
pour cela en termes d'attractivité que
nous voulons par rapport au
vieillissement de la population avoir
ouvert la possibilité d'ouvrir des
perspectives à la jeunesse pontoise pour
lui permettre de rester un abaissement
rester en martinique pour justement pas
lui donner du sens aux liens
intergénérationnels
alors je crois que nous avons réussi
nous avons réussi avec le cioff cas
permis de montrer de démontrer que la
martinique ce n'était pas simplement une
il y avait simplement des plages mais
que nous savons nous
anthony qu'elle nous tourner vers ce que
j'appelle la croissance bleue et la
croissance verte de leur question madame
kazemi rieuse cette campagne se déroule
essentiellement durant les jours grâce
être problème pour vous absolument c'est
un problème c'est pour ça que dans notre
plan nous avons prévu un certain nombre
de rencontres une utilisons aussi
beaucoup les médias en 1 vs 2010
tracteur qui s'acharnent à critiquer
apporté à titre notamment et je tiens à
le dire est une jeune femme bourrée de
compétence au nom de l'apologie pour la
naissance ou l'appartenance commune je
veux dire que si ceux d'entre nous qui
avons eu des expériences
professionnelles augmentent unique si on
avait procédé de la sorte mais beaucoup
nourri par cette expérience et cette
jeune femme brillante à je rappelle
qu'elle a fait partie du cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur et qu'elle est
venue apporter tout son savoir faire et
son savoir être à la ville de bath mais
aussi à la martinique
merci marie thérèse quasiment nul seuls
merci d'avoir été avec nous on rappelle
que vous êtes la tête de liste de la
dynamique après trois bonnes journées
merci et vous remercie matières
premières